sous le couvert nuageux le temps et
frisquet en bourse pas de quoi enflammer
les esprits et pourtant il y a quelques
jours encore ces graffitis sont apparus
tu as détruit ma famille écrit l'auteur
à françois legault et christian dubé je
vais démolir les vôtres en faisant
référence à denis lortie le tueur du
parlement en 1984 je vois tu trouve et
où je vois de chercher où ces jeux tata
ou
manger puis des fois c'était même pas
des gens la circonscription c'était
vraiment des gens à l'extérieur le
député samuel poulin a transféré des
dizaines de courriels menaçants à la
sûreté du québec dans les derniers mois
sans compter tout le reste des 300
courriels par jour toutes les lignes
occupée
même si tout paraît calme aujourd'hui à
son bureau de comté plusieurs fois je me
suis dit pourquoi tu es venu en
politique alors je me suis parler
beaucoup personnellement là pour
traverser ça il faut se parler sur
grosne des pizzas écoute là c'est pas
vrai que mon mandat je veux juste le
passé là dessus la commune se faire du
terrain le rassure parce qu'il peut
sentir le pouls des beaucerons même si
tout le monde sait où habitent les
députés de région il ne craint pas pour
sa sécurité j'ai des bons voisins on a
dû solliciter le service de protection
de lescure à une ou deux reprises la
légende des mieux te cacher on va les
trouver le 1er mai le député de québec
solidaire alexandre leduc a demandé aux
militants opposés aux mesures sanitaires
d'aller manifester ailleurs qu aux
abords de la clinique de vaccination du
stade olympique ça a tiré sur moi et sur
mon équipe d'hochelaga maisonneuve les
projecteurs avec tout ce que ça implique
de discours haineux de menaces il
craignait même des représailles contre
sa famille je demandais à ma conjointe
de pierre ma fille d'aller passer la
journée chez mes parents ailleurs al
hallak extérieur du quartier l'accent de
l'île même un moment donné ça vient ça
vient lourds ou dur à gérer l'eau les
députés d'opposition comme sylvain
gaudreault se font traiter de moutons
aucun n'y échappe tellement que
l'assemblée nationale a dû renforcer
cette sécurité et la protection autour
de nombreux élus on a toujours tendance
à voir les commentaires mais j'arrête
parce que c'était délire tout est mieux
ne pas se promener dans la rue même un
dur à cuire comme enrico ciccone a porté
plainte à la police
la dose et ses interventions pour ne pas
alimenter les discours haineux contre le
gouvernement
de ce jeu alors parfois je m'attends à
la veille de la rentrée parlementaire
les députés se raccroche à une chose la
vaste majorité comprennent qu'on n'a pas
signé pour ça samuel poulin pense que la
majorité des québécois les appuis pour
le meilleur et pour le pire ici vernis
prince radio canada québec